So, so far, you've learned
that thinking responsively,
means thinking about the user
experience for every device.
>From the small screen,
all the way up to the largest.
>> And inputs too.
Buttons need to be big.
>> But responsive design,
goes beyond optimizing single elements.
Now in lesson three and
four, you'll be taking a step
back to design page layout.
Which means you'll need to think about,
what information you're presenting to
your user, and how you want elements
to be arranged on the page.
Picking the right design pattern can
be more of an art than a science, so
you'll have a chance to try
a few different design patterns,
as this lesson progresses.
>> And by the end of the next lesson,
lesson four, you'll take what you've
learned about responsive design
patterns to layout the project
in a way that looks great.
No matter how users find your site.